okay so our speakers been you just
handed over to you use here the
Statistics Department
well thank you for the organizers fries
and Terry for having me
so as free said I'm a statistician and
also have apartment in EEZs and also
computation biology so my perspective
smells somebody coming from outside I
have been working with like a landline
for the last ten years so more like
outside of you but I do have a
collaborator with Jack and so share some
our sauce and also a lot of the
experience are also taken from other
data science project in other field so I
see it a lot of Statistics is the field
that you transport all the good ideas
from field to field and you know really
welcome comments tune to talk so now a
lot of things are being put under the
umbrella of data science and I think
it's for most of us easy to agree that
the three important components computer
science maths and stats and also domain
knowledge here is neuroscience and I
just want to remind us that actually
early developer computing devices were
partly driven by data analysis 1890
Holloway's esthetician census bureau
face the problem of processing data
which was predicted to take 13 years so
u.s. census every 10 years so that was
not desirable therefore he was charged
to develop computing measures to all
devices to speed it up and he developed
her with tabulating machine and the
company that merge to IBM as wonderful
company so this is a history that data
have always large amounts of data
relative to the time also driven
computing development and Fisher was
really a geneticist and the Berkeley
definition of data science is really
where emerging statistical and
computational thinking and machine
learning has been very very active field
about statistical machine learning and
both computer science and statistics and
prediction and cross-validation both
know what their Institute's about Nova
at the center and the first generation
machine are now say they really build on
prediction optimization and made a
highly use of cross
raishin so here we really want to do
signs so I'd like to see
cross-validation as actually application
of very scientific principle right
prediction it's a big principle for
science
it's Princeton you know you have a
discovery you have to be disk replicated
by another lab I mean a lot of the
Astronomy T banner is you know like
Gauss and Kepler it's really about
prediction servers right so it's a lot
it's about one validation scientific
theory is predict the future and equity
and I see cross validation it's really
try to use the same data under you know
considerations up from science and data
collection to say that actually we have
we can think of having four experiments
and we can delete one part and then use
the three parts to predict and we can
cycle through so it's really like a
pseudo replicates idea and the second
principle of data like science and data
science is really replication and as I
said right machine learning really part
of stood here some machine learning and
computer science it's really making huge
strides in all kinds of areas prediction
is very very easy to describe understand
and you have data availability computing
software availability so it's really
really oh you'll hear about it's about
machine learning but I think we're
learning a statistic kind of coming back
together very nicely in the sense that
we really now care by interpretation and
you had a regulation basically users
rights to explanations and now you are
systems we like smaller models and we
want to really interpret in a way that
between scientists we can communicate
and also Peter much much broader
audience right easily you can see
precision medicine we don't have
treatment based on machine learning
statistical measures and you want to
tell the patient why this is a good way
instead oh I'm a good doctor and
therefore you should trust me that why
should we trust a good
the data silent without talk about the
three principles a lot it's based on
research and also teaching experience or
have been struggling to say how can we
make statistic and data design
accessible to a much bigger audience so
I run this statistic last eight out of
ten years PhD level statistics cut to 15
a in Berkeley and two sirs my class and
my students are outside PhD students
they're not religious for so many last
semester I had forty so it's because we
have a seat have a report and would like
to scale it up right so that's where we
are at and when it's like you don't they
don't have time to take two years of
statistic classes and many of them have
been MOOC on their own and how can we
describe org organize statistical
knowledge in a way it's more like
physics principles and so they can get
quite a lot out by knowing the hype
significant bits and go to detail
instead that they have low everything
before they can't do anything so that's
a lot of my teaching thinking merging to
practice
I also like to be able to enlarge the
umbrella of probability thinking to
include like PDEs and things not exactly
probabilistic right apply mathematicians
are very much doing data science so
that's another thinking for this dream
principles go beyond probabilistic
modeling another thing we follow very
closely in my lab is that we actually
develop general methodology that's
basically our task our statisticians
within the context and we try to solve
problems before we say this is a general
methodology other people should use so
take that very seriously that empirical
evidence for something to work instead
of just all some simulations and seem to
work
and so I summer I give you the this is
really going the other way around I have
been working on this for the last four
or five years summarizes caca pcs
workflow so a lot of people I think
already doing this the top labs and you
know but we now want a lot more people
take advantage of what I'll see the top
left doing so that they don't have to
take as much time to get the same game
so it's really building on machine
learning use prediction as a form of
reality check right in classical
statistical nesaf it but in high
dimensions can have to do and we don't
talk about there anymore and that's very
dangerous I have deftly sitting qualify
exams people choosing to horrible
hypothesis but the framer doesn't stop
them from doing that because there are
two hypotheses so that's one thing is
that we need to have some way of
measuring the model you develop somehow
capture reality it doesn't have to be
prediction the prediction is an easy one
to say that it fits would you mean
benefits and the measure usually comes
from the subject matter that our say
that in the first example is really
measure against experience and
computation actually I don't talk too
much about because my lab actually do
computation but I think our strands is
actually post on the theory and the
scientific collaboration and stability
is sometimes in advocating as a minimum
requirement for reproducibility
imputation and recently actually
interacting with Bruno and phrase also
we also see it in real science yes so
actually it's interesting that you leave
out computation because that's what most
of us do yeah but I'll tell you the key
principle in computation is scaling so
someone comes up with an algorithm and
there are a lot of algorithms out there
you should be asking yourself well not
not just whether it is it does what it
claims to do but how well will it scale
up if I increase it by a factor of a
thousand or a million very few
algorithms scale well from AI none of
them scale well and the reason why
you've been hearing about deep learning
is that it's the only one that scales it
to the point now we're seeking on
real-world problems so this is
computability not
mutation vicuna Billy whether you have
actually computed with current Hardware
yeah great fine by the way we really
want this to be interactive so if
there's a man interrupting
you know just to not just to fill in
something but also you know from the
point of view of interactivity we want
we want these lectures to be interactive
but one thing I want to push back on
eyes I agree that so is it the
algorithms that are the problem in terms
of scalability or the hardware both
actually you know you're right if the
hardware hadn't scaled up by a factor of
million over the last thirty years
you know algorithm could have been
simulated but you know it's a
combination of both and what's happening
now is very interesting you mentioned
software for machine learning so it's
now they're packages out there like
tensorflow which run on special-purpose
chips which give you you know many
orders of magnitude of speed-up over
traditional computers because these are
parallel chips that aren't able to take
problems that could be paralyzed and
deep learning can be and it makes it
much more efficient so there's billions
of dollars being put into the hardware
as well as the software so I agree that
computability extremely important but I
always want to push back on that
actually that's mostly talked about want
to emphasize actually interpret reality
and stability you can compute whatever
you want
actually we deal with it but it's just
not averages a talk but the result it's
equally important that it makes sense
and also we can validate it then I
actually feel like it's less emphasized
I definitely agree with you then compute
ability in you to talk so that's what
this talk I'm always about that so we're
also writing a textbook which my student
Rebecca I'm writing a paper on that's
really seeing stability and computable
computers like it's the trunk right
severe brain the support or the fruits
of the tree of data discovery and
stability is also very important ground
it definitely I agree that computability
it's hugely important
I worked if I yeah thank you so
stability exactly right Sims makes sense
and then self-evident as a philosopher
friend from North Easton and he gave me
this code from Plato rice but this white
knowledge is surprised higher than crack
opinion or knowledge and differs from
crack opinion in being tied down so this
is just self-evident that knowledge even
words the meaning have to be stable and
we came today's actually working with
Jack's lab we were doing less suited for
predictive modeling and want to
interpret and then you change the data
by 10% I thought they could decide you
to only spend 10 minutes less to recall
the data you do want the important
predictor to change so actually that's
the beginning of this thinking about
stability and now of course this is
literature and robust statistics and
many of you would have the stability
concepts I'm slowly putting together our
as a principle so that's going backwards
so with stability at me so I started
with thinking that uncertainty and
sample stability right you subsample in
a reasonable way and I'm not really
extending it to beyond sampling sample
variability to the whole pipeline data
science from pre-processing right you
want your pre-processing measured not to
be determining what your outcome right
so a lot of the data as Terry says it's
pretty complex more more the process
unlike the single neuron measurement
this is pretty long with unknown lot of
people actually don't know how the data
is processed and informatics definitely
normalization for omics it's very
popular and there are different ways of
doing it how would you know your result
an artifact of a deeper processing so
that's right there is stability and also
data visualization you don't want to
look at the pattern and I think there's
something there when you change the data
a little bit and the pattern disappears
so its robustness in its most general
form and also human decision this paper
from Liam's group are responding me to
of a high-throughput imaging data
your science they they made many choices
under parameters in the way to going
right they do much is go is about
experiment ISA but they had a lot of ad
hoc choices human made in coming up with
the conclusion the processing and we
want to make sure that's not the
dominating the results so with just many
many things we don't report we say oh we
just said this parameter I said that
parameter before it's less a choice but
now for deep learning like tensor flow
you have architecture you have many
things you can tweak and the words that
you beam can compute but if tweak too
much you're overfeeding members exactly
and also target of interest stability
has to be tight define relative a
particular target since can be stable
for prediction that's what deep NASA's
but not to interpret one of the few
million weights that's not stable right
and also we have to be transparent with
how we decide on this matrix is of
course technical knowledge but a lot of
experience and judgment and even
regulation will come into play so all of
it I like to see a more transparent
workflow reporting to really have them
all nicely boxed and described you know
very clear way so people can decide on
the evidence you present the question
how will you talk about how this can be
realized because it appeals to me this
is really also it's a data management
problem you need to to really you know
in a very transparent fashion they are
able to actually document in the data
said how actually the pipeline is
configured what the idle parameters you
know smoking for people situation have
been meeting you needs to use to Peter
and I pass on platform to record and in
the future can even use the machinery
Ivan to mine so you know we can go into
all the recording the log to know
whether you have patched data how many
times right so technologies are out
there now to make these oh by the way
this is a really
proper experimentalists because it's not
just you know collect the data you have
to specify how you collected it what
were the conditions of the animal what
was the you know the protocol and if you
don't have that in the data set then the
data becomes much less valuable because
maybe that some of those parameters like
the temperature or the time of day may
be critically important and and that and
this is why often things can't be
replicated in different labs because
they don't actually all the information
that you need to reproduce experiment
isn't in the paper that's published this
is going to be critically important all
of this other metadata as is just is is
equally important as the actual
recording yeah I think the committee we
can agree on a certain way of reporting
that I just have boxes people have to
fill in so they can now avoid it right
good labs always do that but not o even
they recorded in their own lab book they
might have put in a paper expertly data
analysis so it's like visualization I
think that's one communica agree l-like
a journal can see this is the reporting
protocol and you just have to figure it
out on github or something if you don't
have space in a paper
so this is a quick slide that this is
you know really unifying a lot of papers
in their literature in my reforms and I
won't go into details there just say
that this robust instability is
extremely fundamental together with
predictability right it's like we do so
many things just oh let's try this like
try that and I'm really worried that in
the end you better reading the noise and
I also want to move away conceptually
from you always have to have a true
model a lot its approximations I think
philosophically it's better to think
about all models as approximations then
oh they are generative it could be
generate but you have to make a case for
it then just automatically say that all
breakouts probabilistic it has to be
generative it's unclear to me so you
started out with these three different
domains right like predictability
computability and stability right but I
guess from a non statisticians point of
view as you alter stability is essential
for good predictability at least in the
cross-validation setting right because
you know your malady
because your data sets are slightly
different the cross-validation right you
left out some data it can be viewed as a
form of perturbation well I would say
that they do overlap I do agree there or
life if your target is prediction
stability and predictability very much
aligned but I'm trying to give a
possibility that stability it's not
about the target your predict is about
the parameters so then they separate
well that's a very good question
the other one was exactly the thing you
just made which is that I mean I guess I
just like to resonate with it because
that indeed right in the real world and
remodeling data that's grownup that the
world is generating I think the chance
is like measure zero that we would ever
get upon the true generative model right
so in fact a lot of the fallacies that
you know we
and you know applying some these
statistical measure thing viz etc assume
that one of those model is the true
generative model and really neither of
them is and so then we need something to
be over yeah that's definitely our wish
but I'm already trying to say something
in deeper so by identify Ren de Mer but
you need to think about the physical
process to generate the randomness and
when usually especially teaching this we
close that over very very quickly right
everybody feel like I used to teach for
20-some years until six start with X - 4
X n ID right and they just now is
horrified myself that's how I did it but
that's how I learned it but I've tried
to move away from that and introduce
random error but we're very carefully
like you just I don't introduce random
urban to mid-semester not want to so
this is something that again you mean
everybody makes assumptions and if you
statisticians make love one of the
assumptions they like to make his let
them let the noise be guy was Ian right
this is someone I was trained as a
theoretical physicist I have every day I
prayed to the God of physics
I'll let the world pick option let the
world you'd love the noise be Gaussian
in the world you know let the equations
be separable and you know you know these
are so those are the only conditions
under which you can actually come up
with analytic solutions or theorems
right in statistics now we're living in
the world where you know in the brain
any images if they're not Gaussian data
and from the brain are not cows here and
the equations are not separable and so
we look we're living we really have to
deal with the real world that's why it's
really even from the statistical point
of view it's a tough problem
yeah it's we should just be very very
easily see with me this is something we
don't have any real evidence for
whatever reason have to it just say it
very clearly
instead of muddled it up right you know
what's real what's not right we all make
assumption but sometimes it's I think
always it's good to say what's really
supported by experience all the
empirical data were just like for
article reason that we have to deal with
it because otherwise we cannot compute
so this is very very transparent on that
in terms of data perturbation but we
mentioned cross-validation but clearly
you need to have maja do this blocking
for some problems for time series you
don't want to do that you want you don't
want to take a block out a lot of the
neuroscience data actually is time
series dynamic so you might want to do
that but you need to make an argument
why that's a good idea
why that's like a replicated original
data so all these different forms also
have assumptions and one thing I want to
point out that for the data perturbation
except assessing kind of sample
variability and all of that that's the
first bullies it's also emerging from
the deep and learning literature that
you can also use data perturbation to
reinforce stability like the adversary
examples in deep learning right you
actually strategically add certain
examples you don't have to change your
item so this is a very much data acronym
centric view that I don't want to change
my algorithm I change my data so I can
have the whole computability of
computing structure intact but again in
terms of regularization you can do
penalisation but then you have to change
your arduino but this way through the
data perturbation point of view you can
keep your algorithm intact but change
the data so that's from computability
point of view it's very desirable so you
didn't waste your time view this huge
computing structure and now I do you do
a different regularization of course you
can moduli things but this way you don't
have to change anything except changing
the data so that's a good idea in this
computing and data centric world
a lot of perturbation that's what I'll
show you that I have 18 models can
equally good prediction now what do you
do right before you know everybody has
their beta tagged away and they did one
honestly nobody can talk to you anyway
so we have to transfer but now if we
data is public as you know sad any
people can try you can end up with lots
and lots of difference on how do we
consolidate this different discoveries
so I said let's do stability let's take
the part that we all agree for the part
we do agree we better say why this model
should be trusted more than the other
one or this algorithm otherwise we'll
take a conservative approach we're not
in a phase that we have too few
discoveries we're at the face of too
many discoveries so it's better to be
conservative I have a problem even with
machine learning Institute's peepers to
give down other people's work because I
just thought the evidence is not enough
then we all lights off because we cannot
build on each other's work so there's
more like political vision of different
algorithms so about causality right in
this game when you sign we try to do
science so we have Hookes law or
Kepler's law that that's kind of the
holy grail of causality and even though
we never really can change to
intervention Kepler's case but we all
trust it but for whose locale to
experiment to intervention see things
happen another how you have statistical
causality or FDA for drug testing we
want to see the average change for new
drug and examine and precision medicine
is coming towards individualized
treatment but you can never go to one
person you also have a small group so
coming back to science prediction we
know it can be just association doesn't
mean it's causal and but if your eyes
stability I think it's a stronger
evidence because you get interpreter
leti and you can go for design for the
next experiment so that's also for
stimuli generation so that's the first
so the rest of the talk I will have to
go so I will show you kind of Oh
technology and go back to 1960 single
neuron management because the exit
stability problem with real data I mean
we don't have multi neuron day that we
can access because I don't you know jack
has some we haven't
put our hands on it yet so that's the
problem I face I cannot access the
modern data because I'm not inside
neuroscience but we try to bring to the
project actually pretty conquer like
some time pre machine learning
statistical tools so that's what our C's
I'm fortunately I don't have much in
your own data to show you and the second
one is how genomics but you can also use
this data this technology to analyze
genomics data relate to neuroscience and
now next you major factorization and
stability comes back for selecting
number components and I'll try to finish
with some lessons learned I would say
the do a workshop and they taught us the
word called scientific machine learning
a quite like so I borrowed here it's
basically use machine learning to do
science so this is a first project this
have been in the work with Jack's lab
with my groups leading it the last four
years now and bam bra and open Wilma
collected the data now about 10 years
ago so the data
nobody has published anything that to
leads reasons to the unsexual here and
item and mike and then so we're looking
at a way for area for this group I don't
have to explain what's before no you
should don't know LEDs okay so this is
among the two we do information pathways
why they're to whines what whines where
so this is the word password you see
rewinds markup or edge detection we -
kind of similar and you go to before
before has been where you lose save to
analyze because it's not object
recognition because that's IT but it's
recognized
sin direct and more complex states so
people have made these synthetic shapes
and to try to probe the neurons right so
that's limited by our imagination how
you make others and complex can be
infinite different ways this is just
what people done and this is not enough
people know that using this curvature
Society stimuli know there's some leaf
on your care about curvature but this is
very very control
and smell nitro at all right if you sell
prefilled stimuli for for single cells
in before yes yes this is you can see
different cells it's not good regulation
to prepare of certain shapes so just a
background for the now neuroscientists
so with you billowy so first put the
electrode in they made a discovery that
eventually led to Miller prize that
unlike in the retina where the cells
respond to a spot of light in v1 primary
visual cortex they responded to oriented
bars and edges of different orientations
and locations and so when you go up from
v1 to v2 to before the cells respond to
more complex stimuli and now this these
are attempts have come up with a basis
up and see whether does it which of
those the cell responds to best so that
traditionally that you're assigned you
have been characterizing neurons by
single neurons by what stimuli excite
this neuron so that's the same tradition
would take so we're gonna use deep
learning try to find those stimuli and
we hope you agree that it's a lot more
natural-looking than this so this data
was collected 71 neuron from a week to a
week my cakes like my gallant lab and
black and white because done quite years
guys so random selecting images being
fit to the to understand a particular on
and decided by some pre experiment it
was up to know that it's before right so
that's the jackleg designer so related
what had the early analysis to being
written for five years now that for to
we can get the state of that prediction
performance what I mean by stated arts
compared with we - so we have we -
prediction results a certain prediction
accuracy and we'll use that as a
benchmark for to understand we form so
we claim a success if we match that so
that's what we mean by good prediction
we use two level sparse coding got
pretty simple relative model and people
we did the workout percent and Chanti
Carlos life has been a parallel
independent as line and third image is a
little different that is something that
you they have objects in post unnatural
but they did very similar prediction
work so we have been holding up and
tried to do interpretation work but we
think our work actually is not the ways
typical we replicate it's a different
lab replicate the result so it's a good
thing but for publication usually you
have a harder time so we're pushing
really hard on interpretation but I want
to emphasize it's good to have our lab
replicate what James liked it we started
with the second question what do we
found around sewer we're looking for
stimuli that make neurons excited
indirectly we learn some evidence to
where the convolutional networks
actually resemble brain function though
we was a private eye we start with our
own deep nets and I was very surprised
by the research showed me that we can do
pretty well with deep learning
so it's transfer learning I'll explain
how has the state of prediction and we
go for stable into the ability over
eighteen models among good predictive
models so image net is this machine
learning computer vision database of
about 14 million they both images into
about a thousand categories cat dogs and
things like that and it's color images
and this is a particular architecture
developed by Alec Schneider Hinton's
group in Toronto which is took it and we
said if we use at a black box to process
our black my image as a feature Kraken
will do something very simple regression
with regularization can we predict the
average response rate of the wave on
your own so one of them is that up and
down its particular neuron responds yes
are these categories provided by humans
yes yes pre classify these that's the
training data exactly so that's why so
that that might introduce a bias right
so before might be looking for something
that amazingly look work pretty well
because we take the early layers
so that was a nice surprise actually we
didn't expect to work so well because
we're doing that's why I transfer
learning from color image black and
white we just make three channels the
same made it colored and this is human
data we go to my cake and this is a very
high level as you said classification
data we did do some post-processing with
you know regression but this is single
neuron date in terms of scale is very
different but amazingly it beats lolli
our own homemade model so that's for me
says that the first two layers of the
three layers we chose somehow captured
something about the primary brain that
to me becomes some evidence course it's
down the proof but I think we're gonna
have accumulation of evidence like that
to say I was really really surprised
because we work very hard to use the
data we have and this had nothing to do
with our input data which is took it as
black box this data was collected 10
years ago right this is much more recent
and then it became very good professors
and people who report that and radiology
right they try to use steep learning to
replace with the ologists reading of
different medical images and they start
the same way we start with something
like this and do some alteration so if
this deep night view down image that
captures something that is much better
to serve on Berlin from nowhere or
activity from the from whatever
information comes through the the bottom
layers the the early layers of the C&L
but maybe could it be possible that that
that information is just rich enough it
could maybe make babies just reaching up
to predict before but that necessarily
mean that it's somehow similarly
processing the data as the brain
I would say that you never know for sure
right but small more such applications
give me always adding evidence that it's
a very reasonable hypothesis hours it's
consistent that's why I say support
doesn't prove the support that we might
be capturing something you could then
show that it the information in the
early layers is not good for predicting
some some things that the v4 doesn't or
some somehow sort of show that it has
also similar blind spots as the brain
does then that will be even stronger
evidence that it's doing something
similar not just doing great but we
don't have the data by night - that's
again the data poor actuator [ __ ] DeCarlo
killer talk just yesterday New York him
and they had a penis paper which was
that when you were alluding to and what
they they said was that if you if you
you could you could take v4 data and try
to see if you can predict it with a
linear predictor from v1 from the first
layer you know that the v1 layer which
is the first one that actually you know
resembles the properties there is you
can actually see the receptive fields
are identical to what you see in v1
right and these deep learning networks
there Gabor functions they're oriented
just like human Wiesel so you could you
can see how well can you predict the v4
activity not very well it's just not
nearly as good as the the you know two
or three layers up and you can also ask
this anything about the top layers where
we know that there are neurons in the in
four temporal cortex that actually are
very specific to specific objects like
faces right can you predict before
activating them and it turns out that
not as well as the middle layer right so
that that was part way towards you know
telling telling us that that there is
some progression in that hierarchy that
is is somehow recapitulating what might
be happening in the brain suppose it's
actually and always they stimuli with
can't feed back into
the electrode and to prove that's where
the you know I feel like that's what be
strong but these high dimensions I agree
with you that the many paths you can do
always prediction right that's why you
need other evidence but usually we start
from a good prediction and to do other
things that we suggest you do
intervention and we come up with these
models with stimuli we think will
promote you know work work at a new
exciting we can feed the back and prove
that but still I mean you know this game
is regression there's many paths in high
dimension for prediction but it's the
structure so you can try to interpret
and now you need to other physiology or
whatever newer modern your own data to
collaborate this two together right so I
was just thinking at what I meant by
blinds was really is that we've seen
that neural memories have these
vulnerabilities as to sort of small
perturbations that we wouldn't really
see just adding some kind of pixels
carefully adjusted I mean some of things
it's a completely different object and
the brain doesn't do that so if you
could show that handle that that kind of
property it's all we can say that
indication of you suggesting that you
for our pipelines Mouse at its most
stable to this adversary example and
that's good good suggestion we haven't
done that yeah
so this is just three models with Alex
Knight vgg and kugel net and the colors
for models and then dotted lines are
real data you can see that we have three
models basic to the same prediction so
quickly I can use layer 3 layer 4 and
that with 18 models they all give very
similar predictions so that's a modern
problem if I have you know classical
data but this is a modern problem
because very easy you know tensorflow
touch whatever they made it for us we
fix the coefficients and we do
regression it's very easy you know our
live on limited GPU could do that so
what which one is going to take to us
for interpretation so we decide to go
for stability principle and there's a
way to prove and from model hacking
people have heard about tea hiking right
you have many many people you choose the
small one the same thing you have many
many more though it's the same things
I'll call them model hacking so this is
a way to stay away from model hacking
sometimes I end up with nothing by this
you don't find anything wrong I think
science is very important with control
force discoveries it's much much worse
to have a lot of false discoveries
because it's making the building up on
each other much much harder so we have
to really really control fastest cars
which we not where many papers which
cannot be replicated now we decided to
go take this deep dream paradigm again
from deep learning we actually don't do
exactly the same we have now for each
neuron we have a one dimensional
response with input as images and we
just work around and to make it maximize
the scottie frame and we actually
maximize an regulus version of that
that's what called deep tuned and these
are the two images from the sumo Don
Ridge model after Alex net they have
very similar across correlation
performance on tae seop's point six
three and point six four and they both
give this curvature kind of indication
right so these are images which if you
give it if you give it to the monkey
what would have stimulated maximally
stimulated that neuron the model neuron
the model or exact it so that's why we
said this character idea and they look
very different
remember all the very synthetic complex
shapes right there's a lot more
natural-looking I'm not gonna interpret
this needle things because they are now
consistent so I'll use stability only
good the big picture to cook but it's
possible that the neuron get equal
excites both of them we don't know
neuron doesn't excite only about one
particular stimuli could be a whole
population so I can give you a whole
population and this is to show you that
the convergence is pretty stable the
establish white noise right there and
then converge to that and this is a way
to see it with paper without the dynamic
movie showing is called super heat to
like a high dimensional data
I have 18 models here's nine of them
this is their to regression there's
three regression therefore equation this
is Alex Knight this is V GG this is
Google net you can see they all have
their own Google net have this I like
looking things again I'm not going to
interpret but they're saying curvature
like things appear so I can put this
back if the electro student plays with
computation and the prove it to see
which one maybe the neuron likes better
and to differentiate it but maybe like
all of them right it's possible V when
you run likes all of them because the
only concentrate on these things that
matter to them this become experimental
design and with high computing power can
do that thankfully etches all of the
same way so if you would superimpose
them would there's not exactly on the
same place we try to quantify actually
that's not easy this but you see we for
also has invariants right so it's hard
to give a continuity to measure we tried
it just they're quite different
yeah but visually to us very simple
maybe
yeah I tried the reserve a few we think
it's more like this is worth the tuning
region smaller yeah it's not the entire
image dear I wish we could have do that
this is the to for this and so is it
more this region I for longer talk I
have that yeah I can show you after the
talk
even though most of you whites yes can
you say a few words about it I mean
looks like Google net is quite different
moon is the largest it's the largest one
yeah what layers are these how many
layers we took the same layer two from
the different nets yeah this Alaric's
really this is therefore I see but there
too is already how many convolutional
layers is clear - how many how many
total in the whole network how many I
think we only look at I think Google
knows like nine more than that 13 or
something you only took the yeah so this
is mounting as convolution layers I
think can you also just say something I
know that this is not about
computability but can you also say
something about how long it took to do
each of these so for this we took
already pre-trained so it's pretty fast
right we only have to do a regression
yeah so this is nothing right not very
expensive so if we retrain it that
that's we didn't right we could do that
go back but we haven't done that so we
took that's the thing we took the fixed
box and use physic traction so I thought
that was more powerful to show the the
power of the deepness then we trained it
so for each if you have start with the
same initialization we have 18 different
such images and we can also try to have
a consensus we just say for each
starting point image we have 18 gradient
because we have 18 surfaces we're going
to choose the direction that's the
slowest changing and take the assign and
move that direction so we have a
combined very conservative way to repeat
to produces images and you can see
that's what we got
so we try to quantify to unify them is
the ollege human look at they look
similar we also did compression removed
80% 60% of the notes and then we see the
pattern remains so it is a lot of
alteration to show that this pattern is
real unless you go to if you remove 95%
things gathered either screwed up but
80% is pretty safe to see the patterns
do there and we also went back to
original image database to see what are
the images excited this model neuron and
you see curvature again in these images
that excite them out on your own so we
just try to have multiple source of
confirmation that this neuron cares my
curvature use the same methodology we
have talib them so now you see the
diversity of different neuron patterns
and it's very different from what you
saw with the synthetic complex stream
line and this look low more natural and
this can be proven project doesn't do
physiology anymore so that we can
feedback I've talked to Jim James at the
nips workshop last year but haven't
really connected yet to see whether his
life can do something for us to prove it
yes so has anyone ever tried to do like
finite difference method differentiation
to back propagate and do a deep dream
style on a real actual neuron I don't
know we we didn't do much that even that
training at all right we took them and
not I'm aware of the people do back
propagation in some sense I don't think
the back preparation will be that
different if you don't divert you to the
difference but computationally I'm just
thinking that this process I mean
love the whole literature about getting
sort of maximal stimuli out of these
neurons okay but it just strikes my one
could actually try some kind of
evolutionary approach or
finite-difference approach to get okay
so you have to understand the
limitations of having a monkey
are you very limited in terms of the
amount of time you have you if you did
it for one neuron I'm trying to do that
wonderfully so does it Connor the Connor
results that you're the other at the
buzzer puffy and Connor results yeah as
I understand it they're actually a
graded they're a kind of descent
optimization virtually show success and
success in such a gradient sorry genetic
algorithm studies through a number of
different shapes and then the whichever
one is the most preferred by the neurons
then used to generate descendants that
have similar properties and then they
choose the Maxima so they're trying to
optimize so there is a approach like
that for dad they've considering
themselves with kind of the synthetic
stimuli yeah but they have some feature
space that they're trying to research
and then they'll see different different
stuff to see so we didn't concentrate in
the image space we constraint in the
optimization space who made it you know
you only work on a smooth surface so
that's how it comes trained so high
level I see very similar but specific
algorithm having a model there's a huge
difference so if you want to do it
directly on the real neural you don't
research space like imagine you have a
plan yet by Calandra pixel such space to
do that search space is too large like
if you want without model doing the
search in that space but what usually
have model like here you have a model of
this neuron and you have this gradient
like the using gradient method to do the
search will be more efficient in this
image space so that's why I like I think
we are doing this in real another neuron
well view Heart Hospital but I think
they can be a combination right so we
can do we can use it to search and
feedback to the see the real new around
so in sort of latest deep learning
research lots and lots of people are
using so-called evolutionary strategies
to the ingredients for functions that
are much more complicated and it just
struck me that maybe once you to revisit
that approach in a monkey brain for
getting an optimal stimulus I think as
you point out quickly that we can have
developed some new pilot study in issue
model and uses guided to so you don't
have the whole space so there will be a
nice combination we have another plot in
a lot of the neurons they not always
talk on some neurons actually like
similar stuff there's another plot I'm
not sharing you can group them a little
bit we feed this prefered stimuli to
different neuron and I really prefer
themselves that deep team from their own
model yes so I have a problem actually
really understanding what I'm seeing so
you said it's like a preferred stimulus
yeah in the sense that it maximizes the
neurons yeah that model generally the
model model right yeah but generally if
I think about simple cells
preferred stimulus is to find under
power constraint in some sense right you
would say I mean in some sense you have
a simple cell phone since when does a
big image space and it's mapping into a
single dimension in some sense which is
the fine right of the neuron so there
are many stimuli that will elicit
exactly the same
so to find the preferred stimulus do
have a power constraint that says okay
I'll look say on a hypersphere basically
what is the stimulus that gives me the
maximum firing rate so there's similar
power constraint here we did it we do
the country on the last function so we
could add the power country in the
search space which we didn't we we kind
of get a smoothness through we have a
regular version of the model that's how
I did it it's a little easier
computation in but we can talk to see
we're not very familiar with the power
constraint would be happy to talk to see
whether we can constrain and what's the
raised about constraint for v4 for we
were I think maybe they're small
agreed-upon constrain for v4 for v1
maybe before v4 do we have a good way to
constrain the space of the images yeah I
don't I'm not aware of yeah so on a
related point it's not clear to me at
all that a single neuron should have a
single preferred stimulus right No so
well a population but she said that if
you start from different initial
starting points you get different images
but they all have the same quality of
look right yeah exactly so we see that
you can characterize remember this one
right well that's just what my
initialization from eight nine models I
can't have many many say with a little
alterations changes from yeah so I
really have a population it would be
really interesting to know what that
distribution how it's related right like
what are they in variances it hasn't
been easy to characterize yeah we tried
it's just Kanta tative to say whether
they it hasn't been easy so modeling
that actually become another statistical
problem but we think we want to see at
least somebody doing some experiment
before we do your human visual system
can't see a similarity right and so
you're right quantifying that is very
difficult but that's the problem of
vision it's exactly the problem that
we're trying to solve yeah I gave you
the APL and the physicist ik look at
that the spacing seems to be constant
which only physicists told me that oh
they're out in the desert right so they
everybody see different things with what
they used to
and that you can look at yeah the
spacing is kind of the same but how do
you find that that's not trivia we tried
a little bit we didn't succeed that's
why we need to fit it back this might
have good prediction performance right
and also in the literature people know
we found you don't care about curvature
these are all the evidence and we also
did we also have similar things from
earlier model two very different round
so that's also thing we have two two
layers sparse coding models which is
completely different now deep nuts we
have similar result so that's why
exactly the stability that's why
eventually the proof is feeded back for
the single new around to get a single
neuron to fire but the prediction
performance israel as i said in high
dimensional prediction problem there are
many many equally good prediction models
i don't know for sure
that's the challenge to go from
prediction to interpretation that's
always the problem and this is using the
consensus tip team you can see a little
weaker signal but this is show something
this a 18 mod have some consistency
through this we can show some constancy
if we define this by the metric we have
some weak metric that their consistency
we take the weakest like the lowest
gradient and take their side
we got something very similar this is
over 18 models right so all of this
we've been beating ourselves to ask
these questions we're ready to actually
write it out for the rest the community
to judge okay so now that's really
classical data to have the kind of state
of our machine learning to bear and do
is interpret bility and try to see with
the how we can prove it yes so this may
be a discussion question but it seems
like you're transitioning so I'll ask it
I'm deeply sympathetic to the idea of
interpretability but I wonder what does
it mean actually and so you still sort
of maximal stimuli that maximally
stimulate to kill networks yeah so you
have for example small models where
interpretability might be easy to
understand a linear approximation of a
small norm solution or low rank any of
these things right but now you get into
a large system and all of a sudden it's
not even clear to me that the image that
maximally stimulates a particular neuron
is particularly potentially relevant to
what the system is even doing so a way
to describe the model actually the group
michael is writing a paper because
actually try to define a few things
interpret bility we define as the main
interpret bilities like today's audience
that would I say make sense so you need
to have the audience in to really answer
the question what's interval T and
there's a lot of things we call a
Griezmann interpretability it's like the
mathematical form where it's simple
enough for people to take a look so we
separate the domain interpret reality
with Ag really interpret reality let's
say the question is a really important
one
because really what's going on now is I
think Republic is how do you deal with
models in spaces that have millions and
billions of dimensions and and how do
you characterize distributed
representations so with the with any
given image you find activity patterns
throughout the entire network it's the
entire network that's recognizing damage
it's no single neuron and so you have to
understand something about joining
statistics if you really want to answer
your question is that human the loop of
women not in the loop is there just
compression so there's a lot I think we
need to design some concept that the
community can really understand in the
same way and then we can discuss to the
next step otherwise we're talking about
different things so this is a good
transition I think that probably have a
little bit of time that is the paper by
Fred rich at all from the MS group
really do with high throughput image
data for large population neurons and
image data so all the share something
not on your site exactly by image data
they use quite heavily constrained
non-negative matrix factorization see
how stability can come to help to select
the number components for them I think
the each component corresponds to a
particular neural activity and for us
it's a curable apologies for pre organ
region but there's a lot of information
of the experience we can leverage across
different fields I think that's really
one thing to be aware for these
communities we don't have to remind the
view every time it's very inefficient so
in that spirit our shared is very
quickly so this is a project which urban
frees from IBL the lead student is a
city whoo and it appeared two years ago
pas paper so this is trying to figure
out how to softlock develop mapping of
cells the different parts in the embryo
stage of free fly develop different
organs for adult life so this is pre
organ region that stage that
pathology doesn't tell you what's going
on yet but genetics already there
so this is we have many many of this
spatial gene expression so this could be
the brain right the fly brain and then
you have actually such a data for
general form that you have different
genes were expressed in in the fly brain
we just haven't use that data there's a
lot of reservation problems and here we
use this Cod feed Mary from Drosophila
you know to salvage the star in biology
has won six Nobel prizes that to figure
out this little water Nobel Prize what
did you see your sock won the Nobel
Prize the people who work under
self-love under never have our six times
to be precise it's a star yeah
so they sacrifice themselves so this is
the region saying that it's in your own
region so this is really people figure
out with old technology and we want to
use high-throughput genes into right
locally they don't just do the same
thing this is a area that the different
genes team up in different ways to form
different few different rooms so giant
wins a gene at different locations they
interact stiffen networks
so after kinds of work that's another
thing it's pre-processing of data we
have to keep people prices for doing
that the modeling it's actually
relatively small part of the hard work
it's registration inspector this is how
throughput data if you don't process it
right you're pretty screwed so here we
end up putting an ellipsoid and tons of
work also using other people software
this is a public data mode thing and now
we downsize it into four point five the
405 pixels for two reason why is for
computation constraint we couldn't deal
with it otherwise the others after we
put them into the deep sauce they've
been stretched we cannot have very small
piece of they won't match so you have to
have big pixels so that they work
respond to each other
we cut the registration well in doubt
actually we borrowed from sparse coding
that's first time I got this project
happen to be doing your son this is a
later project than my collaboration with
Jack we use sparse coding now when mama
negative major factorization so we lay
them out so this could be different
measurements of the high throughput
your own population data and you end up
with different neurons at different
locations so for us it's different all
things right and I think in that paper
they use constrained we didn't use
country but I think what we say is very
similar so he basically decomposed use
positivity as a sparsity country if he
compose these different genes into
different we call principle patterns
that correspond to the different neurons
in in the neuroscience world amazingly
were pleased to find that the regions
become all coherent we didn't put any
continuity constraint they came out to
be like coherent regions which makes
sense this is i pre other regions for
developer ology and what stability
brought to the game is to find how many
principal patterns it's like why I
should have twenty one column turn to my
region so for you guys how many neurons
there and we use a stability criterion
just say that you start from different
random starting point this is a non
convex optimization problem and you
match them to find the best match
through correlation and then you try to
say that uses the word the Y minus the
best match of correlation I said the
similarity metric you want to minimize
this dissimilarity and that's how you
choose the number components so this can
be pulled over to choose the number of
neurons in your processing and we did a
lot of analysis for 22 for the same
stability principle this is awfully
close the data is now very clear so we
also did a lot of analysis saying that
what's going to happen here we don't
want to have a complete different
science because we take time you might
not want you to again stability
what OPC give you checker bar like a
high-frequency doesn't make bad alcohol
sense we did that it's because it's all
positive is the constraints the wrong
constraint the variability is around
constraint you get these patterns
biologically doesn't make sense so to a
PC a couple of things
so PCA is trying to it's really
reduction of the variance into the
minimum number of components which means
they will pack together things that are
really unrelated and if you want to
separate out what are the independent
components then it turns out that tub
and also this that this these algorithms
are much better but actually PCA is if
you have Gaussian data I can I at the
beginning if this guy was indeed a PCA
is the best you can do it turns out but
all of the data here are non Gaussian
and in that case the you know ICA
independent analysis and not negative
matrix factorization have been shown and
many many data sets to give you the
where the joints are in the data and the
independent things here trying to be a
little neurons are regions which are
spatially localized disability the
number that it no so what it did I have
a problem with choosing how many
components I want right this is I lifted
that twenty wines in nineteen so what
are these are fixed the number of
component and not do different random
writes and then I met to have a measure
how the different local minimum that the
the principle patterns are similar so I
want them to be as similar as possible
you know matrix factorization a lot of
time to increase the number it changes
all of the basis functions right yeah
yeah so we choose one that give you the
most similarity use correlation a
similarity measure yeah so this 22
actually split one of the 21 into two
and we use biology to decide that was
not desirable so there's the patents we
get the principal patents and then we
can do some polish on it we can localize
the genes and do local networks and all
that so there's a huge amount of work
following this is the so the question if
this is shaky then the rest just go down
the drain right so that's why we work
very hard to say how do we trust how can
we trust these principal patterns it
came out from a magical mathematical
angle and their options right to two
days we're in that way so one thing it's
important is we need replication images
this is also nice I think in your son if
you can do replication and also we also
use existing knowledge from this
Drosophila to really try to keep
functionalities to compute their genes
basically you can't organize it so for
you is that you have different neurons
you said and also we use prediction
human labeling and the particular known
gene Network and we did Theory too we
end up using sparse dictionary learning
stochastic models to analyze well the
idea so my view on theory is that you
should have multiple models very
generative models and to make sure
you're gonna works well under multiple
models there's more robustness and as
you know why sense reading that's the
right one otherwise you want robustness
I also know care experiments so people
actually the crisper case 9 and try to
discover genes so that's similar to feed
the stimuli back to the electrode so to
go to the neuroscience I see replication
is important and you need some reality
check I don't know that data well enough
but predictions one possibility and you
need to know order this stability is
relative to your data perturbation your
algorithms and ad hoc human decisions
you're a lot of hyper parameters you
just chose would that be
in force right maybe it's not for violet
by collectively we have to really do all
these stability analysis and do you have
new discoveries effects Nellie for
unknown brain regions that's one thing
you can see and prediction performance
if people can label some data and do
well in prediction and also
reconstruction we use a particular
Network acting like what do you conduct
on data can you connect with that do
some prediction with that and theory I
think but you want to do analysis and
your multiple models so that you have
the stability and also can you do
intervention to feed it back so I have a
little anecdote about that yeah so when
I first moved to the Salk Institute
Francis Crick was there who is a God
there in biology discover DNA with Jim
Watson and you know so he's the come to
tea almost every day in my lab and I
remember once he said you know Terry you
know you're very fond of your models
right and you know he was right but
that's what I do that's my business so
you know we all perhaps are a little bit
too attached to what you don't
understand is that the purpose of a
model is to design a killer experiment
that nobody else would have ever thought
of doing that's going to give the game
away right and it actually goes beyond
prediction and B prediction is good
soundtrack but unless you have you know
a really the model leads you to a new
framework and you can test it that's
when you actually have a discovery and
the potential for deeper understanding
and and I think that that's what we're
looking for here right we don't have it
yeah but we're we have I think we have
some of the tools that will take us
there there's a lot of days I'll call
scientific recommendation system right
you come up with hypotheses or something
and you go back to lab to the
intervention that's finding the proof
but a lot of times even in genetics it's
relative simple so you have to bridge
the gap using some theory and many later
technology become available do more
complex extract
so there's some theory relate to three I
will mention for this but I just wanted
there's a theory arm to this and it's
just a summary that for the PCs workflow
I think stability is extremely important
and many many different step prediction
people read about and I think for the
modeling I've experienced that you need
some matching structure matching of the
domain knowledge to build into your data
even with kind of data rich by relative
to the complexity of the problem with
kind of data poor thank you so any
polling questions now we have a good
problem you'll be a little bit behind
schedule but there will be a discussion
session after Mauryan stock so then I
would say let's go into the coffee break
it'll be twenty minutes and you will
hear the bell ring